i am pushing boots
holy spice
hey giant
you want to see something cool
[Music]
and how many times have you died
no already but doesn't need a spotter
watch
watch
a cat always lands on his feet watch
you are down to your last life mama
lunas always on the lookout for a new
lap cat i have no live cat i am [ __ ]
bugs not anymore
this is a person potty pickles that's
your party so this is where dignity goes
to
you diet look like a pickles well
you don't look like a cat
full disclosure i'm a therapy dog why
were my belly
hard buzz oh
they found me
goldilocks and the three bears crying
funnily
make her talk
excuse me my darling we're looking for
the legendary [ __ ] boots have you
perhaps
seen him what a puss in boots
he
is me
oh
[Applause]
normally i have a sword it's like a
whole thing you know okay
get that cat dead or alive will be just
right bounty hunters kitties of course i
need your help whenever i came up with
you things go wrong cool another member
of the team i'm pussy's there veda
definitely not finally you need therapy
oh i have got to learn how to do that
lives flashing before your eyes pray for
mercy from birthing birds
[Music]
i don't trust you trust me
you gotta trust him look in those eyes
you call that cute
no
i'm with a paws am i doing it
stop you're gonna give yourself a hard